[Musique]
après quoi tu coures la vengeance
l'argent
ou est-ce que c'est autre chose
tu es beau tu t'habilles toujours aussi
mal mais ça a l'air en forme
on m'a parlé d'un boulot un gros bonnet
qui veut que je monte une équipe
je suis pas qu'un chauffeur je vois si
un pilote
longtemps que j'attendais une occase
comme celle là
qu'est ce que t'en dis n'importe quoi
c'est retrouver un vaisseau ouais je
connais quelqu'un c'est le roi de la
contrebande
on va raconter une histoire à ton sujet
je me demandais si c'était vrai toutes
les histoires pour raconter à mon sujet
fait rare la chatte et émotion
cela
[Musique]
si tu viens avec nous tu as une grande
carrière devant toi sois gentil attache
pour mon bras
[Musique]
voilà
si je peux te donner un conseil
pars du principe que tout le monde
craint
je serai jamais déçu
sais pas pourquoi mais je le sens bien
[Musique]
depuis quand tu sais pilote est oui
cent quatre-vingt dix ans non plus tu
les fais pas
[Musique]
je suis trop content d'être là